last year a very good friend the missing
word Bergman's accepted the Oscar for as
the acceptor he becomes this year's
presenter a man whose charm is exceeded
only by my Envy my good friend from
Moscow mr. Cary Grant
tovarisch comrade why haven't I seen you
at the meetings
tell me how did you like Russia oh great
but I was afraid they'd brainwash me oh
yes well they'll tackle anything no
matter how impossible just be satisfied
you have longer eyelashes Rob alright
avatars I came home the other way you
have a line here the the picture Ingrid
is making a present was originally
scheduled to start at Hong Kong he had
hoped to come back this way I'll have
returned to Europe that proves a
previous point guard I was about to say
it was there hope to be here tonight but
unhappily the shooting schedule was
changed and Ingrid is still working in
London where I talked to her today she
asked me to give everyone had love and
gratitude for last year's award and now
for the highest honor our profession can
bestow upon an actor first the list of
non nominees Marlon Brando sayonara
Anthony Francie Oh sir a hatful of rain
Alec Guinness the Bridge on the River
Kwai Charles Laughton witness for the
prosecution anthony quinn wild is the
wind and here's the winner Anna Guinness
in the river the fire
Dean seven
Miss Jean Simmons will accept the award
for mr. Guinness to accept the award for
Alec Guinness tonight
gives me a particular delight because 13
years ago I worked with Alec in a
picture called great expectations and we
were lucky enough to have the director
David Lean who directed which over the
River Kwai spins then I've watched him
give wonderful wonderful performances
and so tonight to Alec Guinness a truly
great artist many many congratulations
and on your behalf Eric may I thank the
Academy thank you